I I I generally do believe a lot of my
faith just come from my father cuz he's
an Orthodox Christian okay good but um
no cuz he says it I'm I'm not too sure
in the verses but I'm the way the truth
and the LI nobody comes to the father
we're saying don't give the credit that
belongs to God to Jesus and I'll give
you an example you have a father you
said yeah you have a mother good imagine
your mom and dad brought you to this age
how old are you 16 you're 16 imagine you
turn around and say Mom Dad you stand F4
for me
imagine you've done nothing for me I'm
going to go on than Ali how would they
feel ashamed ashamed betrayed they'll
say what an ungrateful girl good now
what do you think the Christians are
doing when instead of giving the credit
that belongs to God you go and say Jesus
thank
you sheit from black Rin I do
bodybuilding boxing calisthenics I run
out of energy git is a natural substance
found in the Himalayas created by
centries of grass and organisms
decomposing into a thick black goo you
just get a little bit of this onto the
spoon so you can get hot water not too
hot inah so it can disintegrate into the
water also there is some study that show
it boosts testesterone even helps the
respiratory system as well by your now
brother sisters go to the description
box in and use my discount code let's
see stronger better more focused Muslim
men okay guys I'm here with huh Tam Tam
where you from cish oh kurish okay and
sister what's your name Iana Iana nice
meeting you uh you British uh yeah my
father was Greek cypriot oh Greek
cypriot okay okay interesting all right
cuz there are Turkish cypriots and there
are Greek C right okay yeah yeah okay so
um do you believe in God yeah okay good
so are you are you a Christian yeah I'm
Orthodox okay good Orthodox what um what
do you guys believe like do you believe
in the Trinity yeah okay all right
interesting I you don't believe in the
Trinity no no no we don't but I'll tell
you there are similarities that we
believe in so what is what do you know
about Islam um to be honest not much I'm
not very Ed
okay no I'll tell you a bit about Islam
so for example our belief system is very
simple we believe that the Christians
and the Jews for example there are the
people of the book exactly for example
we can marry from the Christians can't
the okay so here it is a man a Muslim
man is allowed to marry a Christian girl
and a Jewish but a Christian woman a
Muslim woman is not allowed and I'll
tell you why however a Muslim man and a
Muslim woman are both not allowed to
marry Idol worshippers so those who
worship idols Hinduism yeah Pagan yeah
so that's what it is so even I am not
allowed to marry a pagan so yeah the
reason behind that is because obviously
usually the man is the one that's
dominant he's the leader he can coers
his wife to become a Christian however
for example if I was to marry a
Christian woman I am not allowed to
convert her to My Religion oh I didn't
know yeah so that's why she's protected
because I can't force my religion down
her throat however a Muslim woman as a
Christian man he might force her if that
makes sense yeah sorry get cameras here
so what Islam has done sister has come
to connect us to God Almighty so what
Islam has come to do is the following we
have many worldly things that we are
occupied with TV Mother's Day Father's
Day Easter Valentine's Day all kinds of
days so what Islam has come to do sister
is to protect us and to connect back to
God so we have that relationship now
when it comes to the Trinity sister what
Allah tells us in the Quran is the
following tell the people of the book
which is you sister Iana Iana so what it
does is is that what I'm doing today is
I'm enacting what the Quran tells me is
to come and tell to people the book that
we come to Common terms between us and
you that we worship God alone so what we
say is the following sister we do not
believe that Jesus is God MH do you
believe Jesus Is God yeah okay good now
let me tell you a few things about God
and you tell me if this is true do you
accept that God has no beginning and end
yes good do you believe God is the all
knowing yes the all powerful yeah can
God die no but I assum you're going to
ask me that's how go how Jesus doesn't
know the day or the hour yeah so the
reason I'm saying that is you don't
believe God can die you don't believe
God can lie no good so we say there are
certain things that we know about God
who he is good so what we say is the
following the reason why we do not
believe Jesus Is God is like you said
before is that he was a human being like
me he ate food mhm now we believe that
God doesn't require food to eat we
believe God doesn't need to sleep we
believe that God is the one and only
Majestic so this the reason why we say
Jesus cannot be God I person believe
Jesus is good du to like um is it
because you've been told or is it
because you believe I I generally do
believe like a lot of my faith just come
from my father because was an orthodox
chrisan okay good but um no cuz he says
it I'm I'm not too sure in the verses
but I'm the way the truth and the life
nobody comes to the father okay he
doesn't say I'm the alpha and omega but
the point is this is if we took Islam
let's take all religions out of it no
Islam No Christianity we don't know any
religions and me and you we like okay
let's suppose we just popped up in an
island me and you and I'm like sister I
believe there's a power behind all of
this we're in Island we look around
trees the sea and I'm like you know what
there's something bigger than there has
to be a Creator good so don't forget no
Christianity no Islam we don't know
nothing about
them if I said to you okay you know what
do you think it's rational sister that
we believe that there's a God
yeah imagine if I was like if imagine
we're on this island we not exposed to
any religion you would would you not
believe in God like imagine if we say
you know what look there's trees are
here where there's there SE believe God
creator good so if I came and said to
you okay we believeing there has to be
some kind of God he must have put us
here for a reason so he must give us a
purpose okay good he must be the all
knowing yeah if I said to you I think
this God is a monkey
would you be like there you go your
facial expression okay if I said h no
this God has to be a man like me would
you would you be
like well I think the the Bel I believe
TR is Cu uh not Trinity not Trinity
let's let's let's pretend there is no
Trinity there is no Islam you just on
the island yeah go how God can't be a
man good would you ever accept my
premise that God is a human being if I
said to you I think God exists he's all
powerful and I think he's a man like me
no I wouldn't believe that good do you
know what we call that in Islam now
coming back to Islam it's called the F
which means do you know we say every
person is born a Muslim it's because if
we take all religions aside me and you
would believe that God is one he's the
powerful he's all knowing and we will
never ever say he is a man it's external
information that makes us say that no I
understand where you're coming from
completely but um I just the things like
um cuz it says in the Bible like no
comes through the father but through me
and yes how we accept that but you
believe in text Corruption of the Bible
don't you we we do but not us the
Christian scholarship says that so if
you re open your Bible and if you go to
certain verses it will tell you these
verses do not belong in the earliest
manuscripts so it's not us that says it
the Christian Scholars tell that the
Bible has been corrupted this the reason
why the Quran was sent down and I'll ask
you a question if God Almighty sent down
a scripture and that scripture got
corrupted and he's imagine he sent a
prophet he sends a scripture to a nation
and that gets corrupted what will be the
logical rational thing to do what do you
think God would do after imagine I
repeat again he sends a prophet with a
book and the book gets corrupted what do
you think logically and rationally God
will do next two Rectify that what would
he
do think about it so there's a book
that's been corrupted would he not send
another Prophet with another book yeah
but do you not believe that that the
Bible I know not the Cor believe the
original in yes but we don't believe the
Bible is in so we say the in was sent by
God Almighty to Jesus but the Bible that
you have is not the
inil because of the because of the
corruption people read Mark Matthew Luke
John who are these people who wrote it
theet sorry sorry no disciples exactly
but we don't know anything about them
but but they walked with Jesus the thing
is if you do a bit of research none of
them did if you do some research like
for example if you read
new J's commentary of the Bible he
doesn't he says we don't know who John
is is it John the preser John the son of
Zeb or John the Apostle we don't know
who these individuals were they were
they claim they say according look it
says according to Matthew according to
you so then they're all liars not Liars
we don't know who they are they never
met Jesus they never spoke with Jesus
but they but they wrot down the Miracles
that he did in the book that's the thing
how could you write something that you
was never a witness of this is why we
see this corruption exactly so what
we're seeing is imagine I give a
testimony and I'm like this accident
happened and he like okay Ali when did
you see this I'm like I didn't see it I
somebody told me so you're not a first
eye witness I'm like no according to you
imagine me saying according to I'm
talking about but then why is she not
here the thing is these things have not
been reliable that's the reason why is
that not like saying how how in the
Quran it denies that Jesus is God is
that like not saying well if the Quran
came 600 years after Jesus then why
should I believe what's in the Quran
over than what I believe he through
Jesus we say is the following sister so
we say that the Old Testament the New
Testament came hundreds if not thousands
years later you get it so so then if I
use the argument then I would say the
Jews had the Old Testament thousands of
years before the New Testament came so
why would the Jews follow the New
Testament then according to that logic
because if you're saying the the Quran
came 600 years later why would I trust
it yeah then the argument will be used
with Judaism when they will say well
Christianity and the New Testament came
hundreds and thousands of years later
they don't sorry they don't believe in
exactly guess what the Jews believe what
we believe closer when it comes to God
Almighty they say the same thing so
imagine they believe that God is not a
man they not believe that Messiah was
going to come and that was going to be a
man who was born of a virgin like how
you believe exactly they deny it so
check this out we as Muslims We Believe
Jesus's miraculous birth his mother the
Miracles he done and we believe he's the
Messiah and he's going to come back the
Jews insult him yeah yeah yeah so we as
Muslims we're saying we're the middle
path which is what the Jews degrade him
the Christians Exel Excel him to a level
of being God the Muslims come and say
can we meet in the middle and say we
don't insult him exactly he was a mighty
Prophet so the difference between us and
the Jews is we don't insult Jesus and no
muslim can be a Muslim if you don't
believe in Jesus the difference between
us and the Christians is we're saying
don't give the credit that belongs to
God to Jesus and I'll give you an
example you have a father you said yeah
you have a mother good imagine your mom
and dad brought you to this age how old
are you 16 you're 16
imagine you turn around and say Mom Dad
you've done f for
me imagine you've done nothing for me
I'm going to go and than Ali how would
they feel ashamed ashamed betrayed
they'll say what an ungrateful girl good
now what do you think the Christians are
doing when instead of giving the credit
that belongs to God you go and say Jesus
thank you instead of saying thank you
God the one who created Jesus you are
giving the credit to Jesus and guess
what Jesus Is God there was Resurrection
well but I know you don't believe that
Jesus but what did Jesus say Jesus
always bed up who the father yeah he
said I am myself can do nothing as I
seek as I see I judge and my judgment is
just for I don't seek my will by the
will of my father why is he keep
referring the father because that's the
Trinity and without if they were equal
why would he give credit to something
someone else so if if for example me and
you were equal yeah and somebody came
and gave me and said you know what Ali
you're an amazing artist and I go well
don't say thank you to me I've learned
it from her that means you were Superior
I've learned it from you correct so then
why is Jesus saying my father when they
came and said oh good Masters why don't
call me good there is only one good
that's God alone when he went to the
Mount of Gethsemane and prayed like we
Muslims pray we pray as Orthodox like
that good so who is he praying to if
he's God the Father I thought he is the
he is the father he is the Son and the
son in which the father and the Holy
Spirit do you get what you tring to say
what I'm saying my dear sisters in I
don't want to hold you too much your
friends you guys need I hold you my dear
sister what I'm saying is the following
if we put all religions aside you you
know what called the F you will believe
that God is one and he's not a man yeah
no I completely understand that exactly
but I just I think as well just I think
with told Muhammad like cuz in the Quran
It also says that Jesus was sinless
correct Jesus was what sinless yeah yeah
we believe all prophets are sinless I
thought what Muhammad was sinless no say
but Prophet Muhammad when it comes to
for example humanly things that he did
he made mistakes but in general believe
all prophets they cannot commit major
sins all of them there's no
discrimination with one other are you sh
or sunn I'm Sunni oh okay yeah so yeah
yeah but it's what I don't understand as
well is how and no disrespect but how um
how if if God was all knowing yeah then
why would he let Muhammad marry sixy old
know that I can understand that in the
time it was different and and and that
but I just I don't see
how a 56y old man and a six-year-old
well when she con married when she was n
years I don't believe I don't get how an
all n God would let a man of that age
when we know now scientifically that a
9-year-old girl and 6-year-old man it
would clearly hurt the young girl cuz
she's not as okay so what we do is
sister with this instance what happens
is